and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners win joining us you know who we
are you know her to do joining us in
studio he's gonna be at the San
Francisco punchline very soon tell us a
little about our good friend Nick
Youssef July 5th or 7th July 5th through
7th do you see Matt punch line go to
punch line sack San Francisco calm check
that out and he's gonna be getting ready
for Conan or what do we do in here ah
let's not talking about that ok that is
super secret also joining us is the
chick who doesn't believe in pulling out
because it's against the law right nany
everyone's the life isn't enough the
gift of life well ok the gift of life
means you have to carry a baby on here's
why I got this for her ok well actually
I have a newborn carrier but she's
getting too big and this I can carry her
till she's three years old and she's a
real needy little thing and yeah she
likes to be held so on walks she screams
in a stroller so if you have a baby like
that they make these beautiful baby
bjorn carry
nice this is a one mesh good for summer
cuz we do get very sweaty people
definitely come the pun strong to hear
the latest message me that are concerned
about my nipples you know okay girl they
give me great nipple tips or some great
nipple tips talk to us a saran wrap on
over your nipple after you put the cream
on so it doesn't get all of your clothes
best tip I ever got oh man well we want
to thank the four female listeners for
Allegra and you also got a what a cool
gift from Ryan where is it the guy on
tinfoil hat yeah
oh no a fight like a girl yeah because
these seemed a you're friends with Jason
than you likely new gay socks what are
the other tinfoil hoes get you yeah what
did you get I let you on the show the
promotion thank you we were doing a
front of the patrons the other day and
he's literally got a mouthful of
crackers
while he's insisting that we start
what's unusual journalist charge he's
got foodies mouth so I go hey guys
welcome to you know the patreon he goes
you know what revisionary history so
much revisionist you can literally
listen to it go to
patreon.com/crashcourse and get all the
latest coolest you know bonus content
it's a lot of fun for the kids
hey Jason where you gonna be guys I'm
gonna be at the silly taint on Main
Street
I love that clock that's a good room
then I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
protesting protesters that are
protesting a protest this weekend and
also omit knock now again I mean Atlanta
on Martin Luther King Boulevard I'm at
knock knock who's there black guy which
is a black club in Atlanta so I love it
I love don't knock doctor on about where
they go get some good food cuz here he
was like the number one regular at that
club back in the day yeah he said the
wings they are terrible no that's good
enough for me alright the watermelon
sandwich those on time energy I'm a well
punch line center of July 5th through
7th in San Francisco and then I'll be in
New York for most of August are you
gonna try to get in become a regular at
the cellar like a couple guys have out
here um you know I don't know because
I've been told that if you do that but
you don't live there you kind of like
just don't really ever get spots unless
you're there a lot it's kind of not
worry not here's going up there a lot
okay so
that's it man my gigs I have yeah I'm
gonna be obviously we're going to be at
the UFC two to six live viewing party
plus stand-up comedy the lineup is
getting better and better you just go to
ever bright go to punch-drunk Sports
live UFC podcast and
and stand up show url' wants to go up on
that well he's bad okay so so Earl so we
got Earl
we got Brodie Steve and Kurt Metzger
Jason Tebow Sam Tripoli who else do we
got Jamie kill Steen and the lineup
keeps growing and that's gonna be after
the fight upstairs go grab your tickets
right now you can just go to the gate
go watch the fights for free if you just
want watch fights you can go down for
free it packs out but this for ten bucks
you get to come upstairs we're gonna try
to watch fights upstairs and then do
stand-up right after maybe as a work in
yeah yeah fights will still be happening
I think it starts at 10:00 the stand-up
starts after the fights okay see that
that says 9:30 because it's time to go
7:00 to 9:30 and we'll do it after the
fight okay we're not fight send the
standup start and then I will be at
skank fest yeah they all will be not
just don't so you're gonna be out there
what your where's the baby gonna be on
her baby bjorn I'm not even kidding yeah
cuz I want to watch Jeff and Ryan's
press conference with Lou so I'm gonna
be wearing this am I gonna be part of
the press conference talking about how I
made this match happen you should be I
should be a partner what else should be
on it but you well yeah exactly
I made it hosts the press there should
be nice for self questions there's you
know yeah Sandra just be in the Octagon
yeah and everyone should be allowed to
look at Sam's fighting a cardboard
cutout of himself we're off Johnny off
mic please stop we have a live podcast
there though right yeah okay so Jeff
will watch her then this is how you do
it as parents the basketball game she'll
be in this well I'm watching you guys
rooting you on she's the mess oh good an
888 number can't wait to answer this are
they doing are they in the basketball
game - who's there
no but I should be there to watch you
guys you know you don't think I want to
watch you what are the T what are the
tubes again kill Tony Lee Jinu skanks
punch-drunk and then a podcast called
come town okay I don't know the calm
down guys
but I'm chilling I don't care about that
they can play basket basket ball patreon
no they have a patreon where they're
making like 20 grand a month
yeah how does that improve their
basketball skills I'll know I would love
to be shitty at basketball but man yeah
I'd much rather our four teams playing
at the same time is this a tournament
what's happening yes yeah who starts
this is so intriguing
we're playing to 500 oh the biggest buy
ones
oh that's the come town yeah I know to
those guys I don't know the big problem
is obviously that the kill Tony is
trying to do whatever they can to cheat
Jeremias thinks he's gonna play he's got
his cast off now oh good but why is it
is so who's on that team uh well it's
supposed to be red band
it's supposed to be red band gosh Jodi
and Josh Martin but they're they won't
let red band play because he's on netic
these are just a he's just a bag of some
static [ __ ]
Ron James Magic Johnson and Tony say I
feel like they've never been on that
show though oh but they're big fans
hahaha but so then they want add the
who's the new like regular doesn't mean
at the end what's his name I don't know
but I guess he put like one in the dunk
contest three times in the NBA so nine
foot for Larry we're gonna add him
unless there is they are Alyssa's and no
black people rule and I go yeah there's
are no black people rule and Candice
Candice Thompson's like what'd you say
no black people okay that's gonna blow
up in my face yeah that doesn't seem
fair I feel like they should have the
the members of the show just like you
guys are I'm glad you agree with us
everybody thinks this you just make red
band play or not or they can't play yeah
I'm that that is logical it makes sense
but they well why don't all of the other
pod
Cass just say this is how it has to be
or you're not you're not playing no one
wants to do that stop with your logic I
mean I'm just gonna protest the whole
thing if we lose yeah we're not gonna
rely minute walls
yeah that's an MRT is their rule Tex do
we get the game the punch-drunk
unlimited vowels that's our team name is
our mascot it's kind of like the other
day he goes uh well because I was like
did Jeremiah broke his arm before we did
so get to know find out who his caste
guy is cause all y'all gonna need his
caste guy yeah and then he goes what are
you gonna do when I shoot a three right
in your face I go I'm gonna kick your
[ __ ] teeth in and he goes please
don't kick they're really worried about
how violent we're gonna be yeah violent
so I go watch old 80's basketball clips
no layups no layups you come in the
paint that pain is gonna be ready gone
it's like the Octagon floor I'll kick
your dick so it's your team is you and
then Tripoli and Ari mostly watching and
panting in the corner like yeah yeah
he'll be on the ground like when they
yeah I played Ari he's great no problem
we're totally gonna win rated or
blisters cause he was wearing his truck
wait who won that I'm pretty sure you
did oh yeah I won I was it classic comb
sock yeah that's when he likes us to
goof he showed up
what is yarmulke on yeah and it's like
one nothing and then he throws yarmulke
he like a frisbee like okay it's time to
get serious yeah yeah that it was too
nothing no so let's get this right July
10th
we're gonna do shove the hot dogs up our
butts that still hasn't happened oh
don't even believe me that's not the
oldest of the bets that haven't been
happened there are bats are two years
old that are my that need to get paid
well why aren't you doing them Oh ask
him okay well there may be a walk-off
I'm never doing any of them oh you won't
even do
but the hotdogs one that's the gross
yeah oh there's oh there's one where
he's got a jerk-off
on skype staring at us intelligence I
can't be on the show ever again until I
come live on this show and prove that I
came on yeah yeah all things comedy is
so stoked about that oh yeah yeah yeah
oh my god [ __ ] off looking into camera
yeah please [ __ ] yeah yeah on skype and
I can never be on the show live again
until I come and prove that I came
that's I'm cool with that
but wait so would be too if I was you
yeah the actual jerk the actual jerking
off like it do you have to just show the
come or do you have to like your dick
has to be on screen no no it's on screen
okay that's not that crazy you just
close your eyes and think about
something camera like this until I come
I can never be on the show again yeah I
don't know where that second point is
but yeah that was set live on the show
yeah just daydream yeah jerk off for a
few like days you can do that yeah oh no
I mean I mean I'll do it I'll be on
skype and if you only thing you'll see
on skype for the rest of the time of the
show question do you get oh my are you
allowed a fluffer I don't know I lost
about yeah get if we'll have a fluffer
yeah there's gonna be somebody blowing
me now no you got jerk-off no like right
before it starts just have a girl suck
your dick for like five minutes and get
you clothes and then turn the Skype on
and then you could come in like you
could come in like 30 seconds I mean
we'll see the loophole I'll pay this one
off next week yeah
I won't beer next week I'm paying this
one off next week yeah that's that's a
little excited it's gonna be great what
other bets can I fix
yes walk cross-dressing down almost like
a [ __ ] for an hour after
night and walk around a [ __ ] town yeah
you're just gonna have to do that one
yeah that's no it takes a lot of time
he's gonna get on the right outfit I
don't have a thing to wear taser my
balls for an entire episode I'm not
gonna taser his balls I'm gonna be nice
enough to push shot-caller on his neck
well that was the original bet I've been
tased like in the leg and on the side by
like a weaker taser it's not that bad
uh-uh yeah let's get that we remember
that river that open right mateys oh
yeah
that guy used he was just crazy punk
rock looking dude and he would always do
something [ __ ] and saying that the
the potluck at this at the store and so
one night he came up and he had hidden
nipple rings yeah and then he attached a
hotdogs and then he took off his shirt
and took a [ __ ] like machete out and
just started hacking the hot dogs on
stage and the [ __ ] pieces flying
everywhere thank you good night like
these are stuff like that so one night
he went on and brought a Taser onstage
and you know showed everyone that it
worked and then tased himself like on
the arm and showed that it worked and
then he tased himself in the [ __ ]
nuts and why did it hurt him he did not
he just walked off and was just like he
was just one of those dudes he had one
of us where his eyebrows dead who knows
unless last we heard he had to leave
town yeah he had some like those dudes
don't age well there's not like back in
my day always have to leave town yeah
yeah he was he was insane and then one
night he was dared to drink his own
urine oh I've done that on stage and he
did it and then went out and puked on
the sidewalk like right afterward and
licked it that's what made him puke and
everything else that he's done and then
fingers own urine he's like oh that's
and then another comment and followed
him out and then puke right next to him
from watching it oh that's the world and
that was the last he was ever seen or
heard from yeah you should get back our
last memory of that guy's I'm drinking
his own piss
well I happened to the who's the crazy
old guy what was his name the one you
love Gaylord Engler and then
and still a lot gather and nothing
happened with it yeah and it's so far I
used to make people give him standing
oohs when he was doing the open mic I
used to love it
him saying he'd go crazy and then he and
I stopped doing Skippy took over yeah
it's good to see Skippy back at the
county store after he flame throat
engine so much [ __ ]
so then Skippy started hosting you never
got another saying oh yeah and Gayle
okay so I don't know since you've left
they don't get it I think I'm losing it
that's so funny such a good time yeah
back in those days when you hosted
potluck it was like you could do so much
weird [ __ ] I can't believe there's that
many photos it's so weird when you go do
some people like they're trying to be a
comedian and there's like why is Joey
Diaz this picture up there for Gaylord
Ziggler dude he has his own wit that's
what I'm surprised by who started the
Wikipedia page on its I know I'm so
impressed
Gaylord dingo has suddenly disappeared
Wow
do you see this it says like speculation
he was murdered in a gutter
how does Boone not have his own
Wikipedia but Gaylord he asked me if he
was on tinder the other day did boom on
tinder I guys sure hope sure hope he
told me central yeah because he came oh
I wish I remember it was like such a
famous saying and he's like I came up
with that yeah I know what is like now
like let's get ready to rumble hey I
wasn't gonna play yeah it's like
something like oh you do you know how I
get in touch with Comedy Central I'm
dying up here but make no doubts about
it they made a Boone character crazy
black trans it was on the Earl I saw it
in the first season he's gonna sue don't
tell us Sherman an iPad tomorrow at the
storage hey check this out
I want to go to Ethiopia do I need a
passport I go absolutely man yeah you
need a passport if you're gonna go to
any country I do and then he goes what
about Canada I got yep that's also a
country you know you need a passport
you're gonna get there any goes wooden
how are people sneaking over here and I
go out there they sneaking illegally you
know they cross the border illegally
then I'm gonna get in illegally I go
where you're gonna get in illegally he
goes Austria yeah there's no bus that
runs to us can you imagine him on a
19-hour flight to Australia
yeah with a shopping cart and like tell
anyone buy this for a dollar
he gets the free peanuts and then tries
to sell the next part of this
conversation is a boon is the only one
on this show who owns a house yeah
that's actually that's true he goes back
to his house yeah and he has like a
storage unit probably so I mean so what
are your sports you like um cycling
cycling boxing Oh your big boxer i
boxing yeah oh really and basketball
sometimes sometimes yeah nice
but once the Lakers started to suck
again you kind of just start
bandwagon no I've been a Laker fence as
a kid I'm from here oh you oh you are I
went to my first Laker game for you
[ __ ] even lived here oh [ __ ] now
that was back when players black players
had to come through separate entrances
that's true yeah they call it the good
old days they come through our entrances
now I watch the firt my first leg again
was at the Forum when they hit yeah way
back then that wasn't a hairspray was
jumpin yeah that was some crazy [ __ ]
back in it Aaron why are you walking off
what
too much Headroom Max Headroom what the
man didn't work who's your favorite
Laker of all time
Ryan I guess LeBron and I can be later
it still is he gonna be a Laker people
keep speculating possible I don't want
him to be why because I was talking to
my friend about this I was like I don't
want cuz he has what probably a few good
years left in him probably about three
or four yeah so you get him at the tail
end of his career he probably would I
mean make the Lakers better for a couple
years but not great not championship
worth and then he's gone and then you
have a shitty team again and my friend
argued no cuz you'd bring in his talent
and you'd bring more you would help
bring yeah more time you leave the team
in a better place yeah but I'd rather
just have them build the team from the
ground up yeah not bring in like now
essentially have what happened in Miami
you know more get your future they're so
desperate to get something back to get
to the champion it's just not possible
yeah it's just like the Lakers are the
Lakers use the benefit from them having
to be good for anyone to care about the
NBA right give the Boston and the Lakers
weren't good nobody cared about the NBA
right so they benefit from what we on
the show called rape traits which were
they get the greatest player and they
give away like a janitor like you get
our second pick and the janitor or Wilt
Chamberlain right and that's they would
get that all the time that was back when
they needed the Lakers be good now the
NBA doesn't need that and they just
can't make these rape trades it the last
rape trade they tried to make was a
Chris Paul rape trade and the NBA said
and and so they're struggling the
problem is is if they trade Lonzo ball
this will be the second number to pick
they've traded yeah and that's never
good that's just not good and it's just
like you have to go through it dude I
mean look how bad ball Boston goes
through multiple arrows of sucking yeah
that's true they go up and down you get
you just can't force it it's not
possible in this NBA anymore to be good
all the time
San Antonio is about to learn
they had two all-time players in a row
like but like right Tim Duncan
then David Robinson and now hey quiet
leads they're [ __ ]
same thing with England I mean New
England right same thing with uh
green the Green Bay Packers right they
hit Brett Favre what do you guys shake
your head well we got a payoff there's
big J thing
how long will hold up how long would you
know keep talking before you realize no
one it's [ __ ] I actually don't do that
our anti foundations of the studio yeah
we go outside and there's just like the
futures arrived as flying cars what year
is it so we're supposed to pay this big
J thing off well he owes his bat yeah
and so Johnny found a gay male for male
gay website that we are going to put a
profile up for him that we get to write
and then for the next two weeks and I'm
sure you're looking that up right now
for the next two weeks he is going to be
getting uh that's that's the pension
photo oh my god that's perfect the phone
really makes it you know it makes it the
barbed wire tattoo like the hair nobody
in your life to go well and the shower
in the mail bad bad rocker bad rocker
his chick sent us this picture for the
bet wait so but that photo why does this
he did that separate like he actually
thought that that's a good photo at some
point just exists I love it that he said
to her cuz that's yeah
yeah she said I'll send you the gayest
photo that I have of him in my phone so
she's into Johnny last night last night
did he sat did he send that to her go
hey babe thinking about you babe look
you just bought a shower and put on a
tank top babe look at my bad tattoos
babe
yeah look at my bets I've lost yeah you
can never you can never be like you have
to get a shitty tattoos as a bet for him
yeah this room Adam for Adam calm oh
come on so box you [ __ ] prejudice home
of content
yeah apparently you can't look at hop
gay porn here fun shucks I'll be jerking
off on the show they thought they
couldn't get it what that sucks well we
can still ride it and just not put it up
come on dude [ __ ] soapbox so we're
gonna we get to write his a profile page
and I wish our Kabir to do this but I
think it right out to gate it no white
[ __ ] please right yeah yeah no white
cop I don't wanna not a minute I'm not
[ __ ] around you don't want to limit
who's responding though yeah just say I
prefer prefer bigger blacker the bigger
the blacker the better but you know BBB
yeah but yeah you don't want to limit
what if he has no limit on what he like
yeah yeah anything right I'll take it
all yeah I'm a dumpster fire yeah for
Cox yeah I become dumpster fire yeah
anything goes please only call after
midnight
yeah so my wife doesn't find out number
and then he's our guest at skank fest
and he's gonna play all the messages at
skank fest that he gets for the next two
weeks I'm looking for a hot [ __ ]
sandwich I'm thirsty
that quotes gonna [ __ ] him that's gonna
haunt me for the rest of my life yeah be
careful what you say because it could
just easily do [ __ ] clamped up it's
just a meme of I'm looking for a hot
[ __ ] sandwich I listed your name in the
beginning Triple E so wait what wait it
was uh hey what are you doing you
writing it down okay okay we're gonna
hang website for Isaac kid did you like
to play a hungry hungry hippo I like to
play that with my ass I'm only looking
for receiving anal and oral hungry
bottom here yes angry nasty piggy bottom
I got a thirsty butthole yeah yeah that
only your Kanaka flavor I got a fever
III want to sweat your [ __ ] have a no
Lube rule oh yeah no Lube yeah
no Lulu [ __ ] superstar
yeah [ __ ] rings a plus-size Queen all
sizes welcome no need to be shy I'll be
shy for the both of us only let's make
sure that you only call after midnight
is a key after 1:00 we're right to sit
down what Johnny's got it
yeah only call between 1:00 and 6:00
a.m. that's great my wife sent word my
wife works graveyard at
[Laughter]
the hospital shift if I don't call call
again you know call a cop if you leave a
message and then call right back
immediately yeah that's how I know it's
you yeah there's got to be the most
inconvenient way to get him bothered
yeah yeah one time I was a buddy of mine
so my car put my car for sale well I
didn't know it just as it cuz I would
always leave my keys in my car Oh job I
had in high school
oh my so he would move it to the front
of like this t-shirt shop I was printing
it in high school with a for sale sign
and then people kept coming and being
like yeah I want to talk to you about
the [ __ ] Corolla for sale Mike's not
for sale he's like what he's got a first
sale sign and I went out there's like
too much it's like right on side of the
freeway too big for sale sign Wow oh my
god that's good and this dude worked
that on that place worked at the steel
mill and Sunday's was his only day off
he worked six days a week like it worked
like a dog and Sunday's was only Daffy
this beautiful house in the beach and he
would get so mad and his I knew his wife
and she be like oh man don't wake up
bill before 8:00 a.m. I'm stuck there's
only day to sleep in so me to get even
with him me and my buddies from high
school put an ad in the Long Beach
newspaper which is like nothing it's
[ __ ] $12 it's like 100 people
probably read that newspaper right but
it was an open house at his place only
Sunday 6 a.m. to 9:00 a.m. and then just
like a high school prank like snuck into
his yard to put all these balloons in
his yard and put open house signs like
all in his neighborhood and then stole
like a for sale sign and then put that
in his [ __ ] yard oh my god like this
and then he comes into work money's like
she wasn't it I got no idea what you're
talking about that's funny and as his
wife Beverly she's like oh yeah people
were knocking on the door like 7 a.m. he
was [ __ ] you know he opens the door
and just sees all the balloons and his
house is for sale
he knew he got dealt with bench
I love it yeah I have mine that's on
this network but it's been on hiatus for
a while meaning I'm not doing it right
now but it's not over why why'd you stop
you never heard of the word hiatus what
why why no but in terms of this TV shows
going hiatus yeah but they tend not to
come back
like no but yeah it's why did you stop
it'll come back because I was just
working on other stuff and like what
really interrogating yeah it's nice
going out with you man
I mean just stuff that hasn't really
materialized yeah it happens Brenna's
newsy stopped his podcast why don't you
give him a heart I guess you couldn't
find enough people to read yeah I'm
sorry about your Instagram account by
the way oh nothing Nick Nick you gotta
it's gets old material and he never does
anything new and original so he did a
joke and the first five times it was
very old material I've had two albums
out I'm on my third our all-new I don't
know any old yeah yeah I know Sam's
account
gags hashtag false flag yeah and then
they have suspended your account no they
then I blocked you now suspended oh you
block yeah yeah oh you're on a cool-down
oh you must have a Sam or said anything
about him other than I agree here and
you're great cuz I knew he's gonna cry
about it
are you unblocked me cuz that's all I
see yeah Ryan he'll still blocked ah yes
what wait Ryan and Ryan he'll do I don't
know man let's say you're perfectly good
account to me it looks like it's doing
well I unblocked you so maybe maybe uh
oh you did unblock me there you go so I
have an interesting question that might
have an interesting answer why would you
block me on Instagram he's back
everybody no I didn't explain it to you
what did i do again
same joke about 15 times and it was
boring so I blocked it
wait so the the offense was I bored you
yes yeah oh yeah is the hashtag false
flag was funny the first five time the
next ten time I don't think we did it
ten even ten times yeah you did easy a
lot whatever the number was it was yes
many
whether it was three hundred five more
or you get a two you did three more
you're saying you're saying if I do
different hashtags not just oh yeah for
sure the same one more interest that
then you won't block me as long as I
switch it on you're dressed like [ __ ]
one day like you come in wait what I
never dress like it's been bad you used
to be really stylish lately now it's
like this weird you're wearing salmon I
just I don't know what how you look like
a rodeo clown at a hipster event I don't
have really uncommon material hipster
junk for the stage here and don't change
the subject
you can't block for that too but you
can't block some black everyone yeah you
can block mom but you I would like to
remind you know that no I'm going to
yeah much like how you can block anyone
I can remind people with this okay you
started this whole thing yeah you did
huh because on my Instagram yeah every
once in a while I would see every post
I don't do every post oh no go look at
your Instagram it's not every post give
way too many oh you erased the comments
probably oh I guess I got some work to
do take so much time out of your life
that's why I do so bit rated yeah and
then you would go on my Instagram and
you would you know leave comments like
I'm pretty sure you were intended to be
funny I I would I would fall asleep
reading them a lot I would be like oh no
and then I wake up
I don't I don't remember them that's
right because it did happen because they
were that uninteresting but when I get
bored of people's comments I don't go
block them no I do and when they're
trying to about it even read them yeah
when they're trying to be funny I got oh
I see what you did there
but you weren't being funny therefore I
blocked you so yeah where were you
but I didn't you were trying to be I
never plan same thing four or five ten
it doesn't know it doesn't matter as a
comedian you should know sometimes you
just do the same Joe yeah but you're
called Bobby Lee in the O R so yeah you
want you want a desired effect and it
worked you know so I didn't fail
actually succeeded by so why are you
complaining I'm not complaining I'm like
you I'm asking you a question
and the question is why if you thought
it was okay to like you know make jokes
on mine and you have to prove I did that
look this isn't a conspiracy I'm just
not gonna waste everyone's time by
scrolling through my [ __ ] Rambo
behind him pull up his Instagram there
there we got nothing to do we got
nothing else to do one time I posted
some like you know the boomerang feature
how you can use that the last one I
remember you doing was something like
that where you were like oh yeah that
stopped doing girl comedy I think I said
yeah I got stopped doing during I wasn't
even comedy just a picture but you're
like stop being a girl yeah which is a
boomerang feature now women I think
that's I was like what does that mean
and I mean like it's not doing what girl
cottonwood girls think are funny but
yeah but that's not what that thing is
that boomerang is only women do that
[ __ ] they're like but they're not always
trying to be funny the course they are
no they're not I was gonna say as a girl
we do not do boomerang we're like what
yeah okay girl and now the talk with him
about being a girl I thought he was a
guy weird so yeah that so anyway I
posted a boomerang something he goes
stop being a girl and then I was like I
read that and then like started to doze
off during it and I was like I saw
myself I was like okay and then I was
like oh he's you know he's trying to be
funny that's fine and it didn't even
enter my mind to block him because as a
comedian so did I write that ten more
times no that's not that if I don't like
it yeah see the point that's
specifically put here if you about the
same dumb thing over and over you that's
all point is that the whole point of
whole point no it's never to cool down
you have to go yet you can't take a joke
it seems because you started this whole
thing and I was like okay you're leaving
comments on whatever yeah and then one
day I was like oh you know what my turn
I got some time to kill him and then
fall slide because they're mug fall slow
yeah yeah the first five right the next
parent it really it really isn't too
much though because I'm basically doing
an accurate impression of you know every
time I see you you're talking about a
false flag every single time oh anything
in America happens Bulls blood bro
that's true that's a different podcast
we can do that in a different part we
don't like talking conspiracies on
partners on this trip we love there's no
there's no conspiracy about your
inability to take a joke no nothing and
that's one of the that's one of the
cardinal like offenses of comedy no yeah
is not being enough dish it out can't
take it so the first five times you did
can't take a joke yeah I laugh the
15-time I'll be tell me bring all back
up it's a higher number like if I miss a
rose the first 280 time to this party
but the next 500 the MCA
three and he never come in here so yeah
dude I I my question ultimately is can
you take a joke you're playing the role
of a I love as a comedian as a comedian
yeah should be able yeah take it you can
deliver them yeah perform that yeah you
write them on people's Instagram account
thank you but it seems that you can't
take one no I mean I can't take the 15
times that's why I'm Ted that's the rule
I think we show you over time what it
seems like it's not about the number of
tone is about the number because your
block Johnny a block Ryan yeah who would
ever block Ryan Oh Ryan Kent does the
same thing since same joke over and over
again but it gets blocked but he's like
the nicest guy and doesn't matter same
joke over and over again so if people
mix it up they don't get blocks yeah but
then now I know my mission there you now
I know what I heard mix it off yo hands
are always negative gotta go
I don't do negative what's negative
what's negative gotta go what's negative
you gotta go about gotta go to hashtag
false one
what's negative about the hashtag false
flag tell me what what falls play you
just literally said are you doing is
talking about false like what was that
positive it's like you don't remember
okay oh you're talking about that's how
that's how negative talking that's not
negative yeah oh that's just I'm just
pointing out pointing out what you do Oh
any I was like man there's like six
pictures up there I'm just pointing it
out
we're not like every time I see you
talking about false flags but wait I'm
into your defense anyway this is gonna
get all it's gonna get old fat you're
gonna block yourself from talking about
I've been an hour he's blocking himself
this is what's happening right now
you're getting to a point where you're
unable to take it anymore
so you're gonna run away go around five
form one block what it for someone who's
now close we offer someone who sounds
close with for someone close so obsessed
with the truth you are making a lot of
[ __ ] all right man keep it going you are
making this [ __ ] a conspiracy show about
the way you view love if there's a lot
of any show about my conspiracies that
would be awesome yeah I spin off - yeah
it'd be an illusion since Chris Hardwick
doesn't have that thing I wish you'd
have conspiracy talk after my right
[ __ ] podcast so the last time I saw
you I remember specifically I were
walking in the parking lot and I was
like hey Sam what's up and you were like
false-flag bro and then he just kept
going and I was like Jesus now he's not
even get on what I did that later I go
no keepin you were walking up and your
weekend at Bernie's look what you're no
colors matching hipster [ __ ] look yo
sir oh yeah keep [ __ ] commenting false
flag and I blocked him and that's the
end of that was after you blocked me
yeah what was that dry block yeah yeah
and then your reaction was no that's why
y'all fall flag which I did that
separate day you're coming in and
getting hurt your car you ain't coming
and I was like hey Sam you like false
flag bro no one ever believes me I I was
because there was some shooting that
happened in a bet whether I ever let him
out of cooldowns go to bed psi psi for
all your betting needs that's why I go
to bet DSi the other day calm use a
promo code
punch
25 and you get $25 bedding cash how
crazy is that dude it's really easy so
let's say you deposit $200 right
they'll put $400 in it BAM Oh dumpling
made 200 you 400 then will you make the
same bet too many times I'll ban hey
[ __ ] with the reads punch use the promo
code punch 25 ha
we we have the NBA player but baseball's
heating up World Cups gray women's beach
volleyball UFC 226 is coming up I throw
you bet that's where you bat make the
bets there you go parlay on that one
yeah Cormier has a shot deal sorry I was
very entertained by that Courtney has a
shot yeah I think he loses what does
that even mean an ominous sounds stupid
I don't know if I don't know if I don't
have no clue it even Mirabal silently
watch World Cup win something like when
something happens like anybody tell me
what false like I know I'm trying to say
right now
so okay say that there is like a mass
shooting or something like that right Oh
probably next week oh yeah or like now
all these conspiracy people decide that
that it didn't happen or it was stayed
like false news no oh then what is it
this is punch-drunk sportswear winners
win we're winners win people are gonna
send us a link later we'll read it so
anyway are you
answer my question all I wanted to it
was an answer to the question that you
change the subject like 80 times are you
able to take a joke you're a Kimmy
you're a comedian
that's your job yeah that's the life you
live yeah I'd write a joke you cannot
take it yeah you can yeah so then why
when people joke with you because it was
the same dumb joke I we've already
discussed this but it's no it's not yeah
it is but your joke was dumb when I
served the five times wait a minute ken
block Barney when you block Ryan Donny
like to get blocked he knows how the box
is my relationship with javis all these
like other others that he's shaking his
head like no I don't like getting block
dude I don't mind I listen dude I like
done and go grab some lunch I don't need
to be that's not an answer
yeah that's not an answer to the
question yeah first of all you're
supposed to be a comedian that party a
comedian is out
I'm telling jokes dishing it out and
taking it so when you are dishing it out
to me and making you know jokes about
I'm a teenage girl because of some weird
sexist view on what how boomerang or
whatever your tight jeans yellow sperm
cow yeah keep going keep going
I'm telling you old pretty quick
just answer go the question are you
going I'm not here to do this but I
don't really care I really don't care
what no I've tried to move on the
subject 18 [ __ ] no but you look you're
more than welcome to move on but you're
not answering the question the question
was answered Nick no it's I don't know
why this is going on right now I'm not
enjoying this once again because you
don't want to shut the [ __ ] up you
blocked me on Instagram yeah I told you
I block for no reason okay for no reason
no I told you I because you're
unoriginal after the [ __ ] five jokes
okay that's why I blocked you so what is
it so I don't understand you Quinn is
going on right here because if you want
daddy to get mad daddy's gonna get mad i
bunt you on the [ __ ] show to promote
your [ __ ] [ __ ] and now you keeping it
going
so do you ever get this for
first he he brought me on the show he
brought me on the show
hey did you're not on the show unless
they say yeah bring him on the [ __ ]
show I don't know what's going on here
every 18 every other time I've done the
show bring the [ __ ] up we can do it I
don't need this shut up why are you
getting mad over this why are you
getting Joel I fifth through seventh San
Francisco punchline
tickets are still available that mad
about the punchline
I think SF punchline com it's on my
Instagram does the language cough I want
that link in my tickets so so yeah
you're the artists how he screams I'm
unblock fight like that
I'm unblock Don you're gonna get blocked
I don't think yeah but he did say before
he left he said if any if anyone wants
to bring this up again I think a good
place to do it would be in Sam's
comments on his Instagram so if you guys
want to talk about are you whether
whether or not whether or not he can
take a joke because he's not here to
talk about it so in Sam's Instagram
comments I'm more than willing to have a
discussion with anybody about whether he
is unable to take a joke or or whether
he can so I think if you got like every
comedian in a line and asked them that
they would say no but then how could see
him argue with everyone I think he like
hey down calm down
I think you shut the [ __ ] up I'm like
what
I think are you really getting this man
I can't believe you got that mad no
really that was the weirdest yeah
storm-off I've seen it was weird how
often does he storm off often every
other episode now every other every
third episode he doesn't like when it's
on him like if we're [ __ ] on Jason
it's fine I'm [ __ ] on Ari it's fine
but he does not like when it's yeah I
mean I wasn't even like really poking I
was like no it was funny I thought the
argument was funny it was very intimate
sense to me I'm like you were [ __ ]
with me and I didn't think it was funny
but I didn't block you and then I [ __ ]
with you and like there he goes it's you
know the same there was the same comment
five times or whatever the number jumped
from five to twenty or whatever but so
that that's supposedly not okay I'm like
but what about everyone else who didn't
do that and then he was like I don't
want to talk about he had no answer to
it so it's like so it just sounded more
like he was unable to take jokes when
they're about him when they're directed
to him but he wouldn't and I was like
all I want you to do is answer that and
then I was ready to move on I'm not
trying to make the whole [ __ ] show
about that but he wouldn't he wouldn't
know hey man already do this and then
Ari and I pointed out like he goes in
circles like how ya doing today like you
fight like a kid or I think I said that
was like you fight like a kid or there's
no you can't get through to them yeah
believe believe me I was not trying to
like oh let's do this for an hour but
just just answer the question and then
we're done yeah so anyway in his
Instagram comments we can continue this
conversation talk about other stuff but
you see what is a false flag anybody are
we can look it up for the actual
definition yeah I bet
why would ya it's like a major a major
catastrophe that's actually a ploy to
get guns out of our hands or okay
distract from another problem of hers so
a lot of what they do is like so like
one of the most like offensive
accusation that's ever been made was the
Sandy Hook shootings we're a bunch of
[ __ ] five-year-olds got shot
people these conspiracy people were
calling that a false flag so they were
saying that that it never happened yeah
that the parents were crisis actors they
were hired to pretend that this shooting
happened and their kids died so we can
get guns out of the hands of everybody
in America and guys like Alex Jones
totally like totally worked
yeah yeah yeah yeah nobody has guns yeah
if these are by the way are false flies
in Christ actors like they need a better
script like this isn't even worth not
working yeah why why like they
apparently suck at this so but yeah so
anyway he's always like ooh bro was a
real you know so there was a shooting in
Florida where someone had like that
their gate Club no no I thought at the
high school it was like a a photo of the
kid the Maine kid that's been doing a
lot of like speeches as being they were
like he doesn't even go to that school
he's a crisis tack he goes with school
in Redondo Beach like what so someone
like posted a photo oh I saw that yeah
and it was just a cropped photo and they
just put it in a different year and they
go and they go he went to Redondo Beach
and you're like what what proof is it
just says you some person just said
Redondo Beach since someone else posts
actually here's the full page and it's
his photo on a full page with other
students and the cover of that book was
the [ __ ] high school in Florida that
he actually went to and I mentioned
mentioned that to Sam he's like no bro
you don't know I'm like I do know it's
right there
and he goes no there's more to and I'm
like what he's like it doesn't matter no
one will believe me and that was the end
of the conversation that's when I
started doing that I was like oh that'll
probably that'll get to him this episode
might not even come out because he just
told us this is his show if he didn't
want you on you wouldn't be on he's in
charge of him so he might block this
episode yeah probably gonna text later
about not taking this down no it'll just
be like only air the [ __ ] Sam talking
just Betty si that'll be our only part
of the episode would just be the one
minute Betty it would be hilarious to
cut out everything else except just say
I'm talking to no one and the laughing
just causes all of us money to come here
I feel how I felt that time I brought
cookies I feel very
like I need to fix this he actually
don't understand like what he by the way
I'd like to bring him another fact he
didn't actually last a full hour I just
want
he said I've done that I've done my
outer crisis actor we're still only at
54 minutes yeah maybe it's a crisis
actor definitely acting like he was in a
crisis oh yeah so we got to work on that
thing right is know something you had
okay why don't we just sit here Johnny
just don't drink Sam's coffee lord knows
what's in that I know finishing I really
thought that what he was not being
serious until he started talking away
from the mic yeah he stood up and I
started point I'm like why that's how
they did calm down he said shut the [ __ ]
up or whatever said I'm like God and
then he nah dog me he's like nah dog I
was like whoa I was it is that really
brought to you nerdy down I love that
well it was up for a long time it's the
most entertaining thing okay so we need
a username for a big jail if we're just
gonna get right into this well uh okay
username for him Gabe queen god Gabe
Queens Gabe yeah Gabe cleaner then you
know for sure he's a bottom hungry
hungry lot but Hall is do we want to
spell queen properly or with a w qw
oh yeah that's a regular regular regular
I'm worried that might be taken or maybe
K W or even better three kaseman oh yeah
ridiculous racist k good yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's great
oh man that is so great okay I guess so
we should put maybe do we want to I'll
change the email address there we we
probably use his email address right too
so he gets those emails awesome yeah
okay um age I don't know his ages what
do you want to put for that let's put
where does it look my way younger than
this put 21 you could go 21 question
mark no do the can play 18 to 35 I'll
put that in the profile okay he's an
actual 8 yeah for the for this because
people can search by what would be like
the most common so we wanted as many
eyes on it as possible probably like 26
or something yeah late twenties yeah go
like yet 27 yeah yeah 27 okay 27 but can
play I'll put that in that program yeah
I'm willing to play 18 to 35 or like a
wink-wink efface okay the other thing
that was funny is he when he said it's
four against one
I'm like I'm off Mike first of all time
ago rewind and listen to this that was a
false flag like my graphics I feel like
you guys are like I've been holding this
in forever I finally gets yelled at what
are you talking about even said anything
you haven't said no but you get what I
mean like you to just like to fight so
it's like any fight he gets right like
he's mad at me about it man I barely
said a word no oh yeah you always know I
didn't say it goddamn thing oh god how
tall do we think everyone likes a tall
guy can you put six five in heels weight
probably like 195 yeah sounds like a lie
yeah alright he's new york new york is
that right mm-hmm
okay let's get a neighborhood for Jay
here cuz we want people to actually see
him in his neighborhood does he live in
Brooklyn alright you can choose a
headline which is gonna be like the the
message that everybody sees when they
encounter a profile hungry hungry
butthole
[Laughter]
hungry hungry puzzle and we're gonna add
the photo later
what about newly single ready table oh
yeah he's gotta love to get pita yeah
yeah yeah you have to get every fetish
unimaginable so you can get many people
absolutely yeah and it's got like a I've
been checking this out it's got like a
long list of options for the size of
thick you're into the big there's all of
them yes any like when you're booking a
flight like morning Annie
that's so funny dude no poor Sam I got a
it would be so funny if he went to get
an oil change and they're like hey man
the weights like two hours now is that
kind of busiest time of day you can find
something to do for the next hour too
what do you think having him back he
just has no regulation for like conflict
resolution you know I'm saying like that
he didn't get that gene let's go he used
to be more mellow did he about that oh
he used to be able to take a joke you
could like and he would you go back and
forth a million percent yeah
and with I mean that's the Sam I know I
didn't really did not expect that I mean
he literally leaves every third episode
now yeah with the fans his thing is he
has this easy line he says it's free
content I don't I block people who
complain about free content but with
comics it's a little bit harder to
justify blocking them that's because
he's blocked you know we went through
the punch-drunk account one day and
there were just hundreds of people
blocked
that's where hundreds really
I don't even read comments for the most
part like you know I'll go back like oh
he's after a couple days and be like Oh
someone left to comment or something
like that but I don't like if I post
something I don't look at it for a
couple days yeah let alone block anybody
that you know
thumbs down and he is funny you know I
mean he's a great guy it was also
another I posted one comment that wasn't
false flag it was something about a meme
that he posted that had just too much
riding on it
yeah meme should be like a couple
sentence right you know but I'd just
like 9 quotes and all this stuff and I
made some comment about that and then he
responded I responded or whatever but so
that's one less actually than the five
that he claims well he blocked me just
for point he posted a couple of things
that were total [ __ ] just completely
easily disproved by one Google search
some conspiracy [ __ ] and I just say hey
dude that's not true what you just sent
out to thousands of people blocked that
was it I mean it was something really
crazy - it was like the moon landing or
something about life something truly
[ __ ] crazy he's like dude I'm just
asking the question that's this line the
answers
not that easy because you can google
anything and then just because it's on
the internet doesn't mean that it's real
yeah you can find an answer to anything
you want well I mean it was like
Encyclopedia Britannica the answers yeah
I'm saying but I'm just like you know
yeah we're we got now you just click in
the guys's yeah I'm I got somebody and I
wish that that you could access these on
the screen why do they have it but why
do they have content like that block
don't they know that's the [ __ ] is the
studio cuz we're not allowed to show
that like we're not allowed to show our
ease nudity I know I guess the studio
actually I don't think it's ATC I think
it's just because that the the thing
that comes up is the logo of the studio
okay yeah I'm sorry they have the
internet from Jacques so you're Doug
Stanhope's website was also blocked well
that's why
perfect house it's mine that makes it
yeah thank you mmm hold on I gotta click
on some pictures of street signs should
you trust that it has no label you know
we might have judged it I label was cut
peeling off sorry so what I think we
were workshopping the headline again
what was I know my suggestion was newly
single and ready to tinkle and what was
yours hungry hungry buttholes hungry
hungry butthole I'll put that in there
first you can come by you can find a way
to combine those unless there's a
character limit no well maybe
hold on I'll put that note this hungry
hungry butthole is newly single you're
ready to take yeah I cannot wait to hear
the messages he gets I mean it's gonna
be insane
and I think right at the gate it should
be first of all welcome to my page yeah
nice to meet you you know what should
his personality be like should they be
like kind of like Queenie and like
welcome to my pad like that kind of
second of our is he like a [ __ ] I do
we'll say no to no one yeah
all are welcome all offers considered
yeah every offer considered and accepted
okay what is it there's a term for that
where you're attracted to like anything
yeah you're like a yeah a pansexual is
there another term for really there's
people that'll take anything I'd love to
meet yeah I'm pretty sure it's pansexual
where you're just attracted to like I
think that's like all genders oh it's
not like yeah not like inanimate objects
yeah but Amba sexual maybe I think let
me look at pansexual if you hear no a
lot you won't from me but my like search
history today's gonna be like false flag
pansexual like a weird gay thing
punch-drunk yeah tomorrow I'm gonna be
like wait what are all these pages what
about my safe word is harder yeah yeah I
say furnace don't stop
so pansexual is not limited in sexual
choice with regard to biological sex
gender or gender identity what a
liberated mind is there a slang for that
up for it like a panty Yeah right
I think it's a penis cuz then yeah
having slang could probably help am i
I'm a frying-pan sexual want to find out
what that is
come on bye see you in so there they
column okay I need like it goes even
down into Brooklyn what new and it's
just got a list of [ __ ] neighborhoods
I don't know I just pick whatever I know
it'll be a populate like a highly
popular yeah Manhattan if that's an
option well okay so you want to go back
up from Brooklyn to Manhattan or what's
the gay part of Chelsea yeah that's like
the gay neighborhood okay so I like the
price that's what we should do yeah
perfect place storefront Sam's gonna be
so mad he might take a week off he might
he might think it we got off right help
me no one on the show next week then
because well just put me on skype I'll
be talking reading like the jerking off
yeah he really went fast I could tell he
was starting to look at me like dude
this needs to stop are you are you his
way well no I I think he thought he was
starting to get the feeling that he had
been kind of a setup like this whole
thing was a setup I imagine you know
exactly okay we have created his profile
now let's just go in and do it sorry on
next week he bought me like a month ago
I don't know and maybe on sky if you
want our I really didn't know I didn't
know he unblocked me I'll be here here I
think he did it well I was gonna pay off
the jerk-off back oh really yeah but if
no one else is gonna be here I'll be
here
but if everyone's gonna be here then
I'll stand so you're really just not
coming to jerk off with us yeah I'll
just stay on skype and I'll jerk off for
two hours and I won't say a word okay
what's his profession about LeBron for
two hours
well what's his profession do we want to
say he's a sword swallower of course he
did that was his first thing I bet he
went to all this I stopped using Twitter
I don't even know that would like
blocked you on here oh oh my god this is
so funny
it's next section is more info hobbies
etc ah let's see just a review we have
hungry butthole newly single or ready to
tinkle that's all we get room four
that's my first of all welcome to my
page hold on it's impossible to [ __ ]
scroll down nice to meet you second of
all I will say no to no one all offers
considered and accepted if you here know
a lot you won't from me my safe word is
don't stop six foot five inches and
heels it's harder better what's a better
safer it harder or don't stop I mean I
like both harder hard or go harder
instead of don't stop my safe word is
harder okay economy of words
professionist sword swallower and we
need some more info hobbies etc hobbies
boner pills do how do we want it to
partially come off realistic maybe he
got the note that good will that help it
work I think will that help get more
messages I think so yeah what I think it
will help get more mess if we do like if
we have like some realistic screens out
yeah yeah like I you know artist like
what like like he's had a tough time
date hobbies like yo you know yo like
key obviously
keep the the thing you said but I've
never been on I've never gotten like you
know oh I see this is my first time on a
site like this hot yoga kind of [ __ ]
yeah yeah that kind of stuff cold yoga
you guys look a girl wants to call into
the show today oh yeah so huh so yoga
are you good how would we know if it
calls antiquing Bri well that's another
one antiquing
antiquing yeah and then what was the
thing you said the first cold yoga Oh
cold yoga antiquing don't know that's a
joke
yeah okay what we need a little bit of
sort of a bio information you know like
us like maybe he just came out to his
family or you know something to make
people empathize with my hey you know
what if I throw this guy dick what about
just uh what about this what about just
Scott my wife just died no no what if I
just got laid off okay
and so that'd be like aw poor guy and
I'm you know I'm gonna spend the next
you know couple months just kind of like
working on me yeah working on me meeting
new people having new experience yeah
exactly exactly so it shows that like
this guy is kind of going through a
rough time but he's got a lot of time on
his hands to hang out and just get his
ass black I like hang out and just get
my ass busted how does that story well
like don't or only call late at night
though cuz my wife isn't here oh yeah we
need to say okay what do you want to say
about when to call and went the message
am I sleep during the days my job was
like third shift so I sleep during the
day even though I don't have a job
anymore
yeah well where were we see the
I worked the hospital shift at a
graveyard the hospital so please only
call between 1:00 a.m. and 6:00 a.m. oh
another thing Sam said that reminded me
of something
July 5th through 7th San Francisco
punchline tickets still available Nick
Youssef comm waste sighs all right what
are we thinking like a 30 30 30 30 no
it's good I mean that picture yeah 30
three or four 30 44 okay body type here
we go slim average swimmer athletic
muscular bodybuilder large large large
is vague enough but here's I'll only say
this people on this website apparently
can search very like in a granular way
so if they don't want large they can
exclude that really easily but I'd say
average then okay yeah yeah average hair
color black blond brown brown brown
brown yeah okay
body hair smooth shaved body buzzed body
somebody hair hairy body some some some
body hair okay ethnicity we get the
whole thing here with Caucasian I guess
white or white looking for friendship
relationship one-on-one sex group sex
fetish cam love fun no strings attached
dating chat networking all of that right
all of it everything everything yes
networking yeah yeah sure I know that is
an odd one this card's thank God you can
pick all of it okay what's his scene
casual conservative alternative drag
trans leather military leather jock
trendy you can only pick one jock trendy
or punk
wait so start over casual conservative
those are two separate wants casual calm
a conservative comma alternative
drag-out slash trans leather military
jock trendy Punk
I'd say alternative
okay this is kind of like I got that alt
rocker so really shitty it's kind of a
little bit of a bunch of stuff like punk
and it yeah so yeah I think out yes or
no what would be a better what would get
more people yes I think yes yeah cuz
yeah maybe some people don't want to
[ __ ] with someone that's like slinking
oh yeah hiding stuff doesn't smoke so
maybe yeah we gotta get rid of the wife
thing so we can't but what are these
smoke yes no or socially we can say say
so socially yeah that's a good one drink
no occasionally often socially socially
again yeah socially yeah drugs same same
options for drugs
socially zodiac sign socially I don't
know what's the [ __ ] another great
search thing they have in money now
here's a good one
sexual roll bottom top versatile
versatile aural versatile top versatile
bottom versus how versatile smile we got
a pic a dick size and it goes in half
inches from three all the way up to 20
that's crazy I would go Jesus Christ I
would go really like three inches bigger
than my dick I would go realistically
large like nine inches eight eight
inches so like 15 no ha maybe like eight
or nine seven eight nine eight and a
half yeah sure no okay because the half
makes it seem more realistic yeah is he
circumcised or not that's yeah what's
more popular probably a second place
right practice condom or bareback
bareback no brainer let's get all the
diseases HIV status
I don't know negative positive positive
undetectable negative and on prep that's
even better look at the [ __ ] that keeps
you from getting it negative and on prep
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yes a pill you
take right before you go okay yeah yeah
right before you bottom yeah yeah
now meeting place the preferred meeting
place my place your place or public
place let's say his place yeah yeah so
he's hosting as they yes he's the host
all right let's say this for that and
HIV much like Sam was on this podcast
he's but now he's positive but
undetectable unfindable and I'm fine
hungry butthole newly single ready to
tinkle first let's just review the
profile again because we still have 500
characters we can use first of all
welcome to my page nice to meet you
second of all I will say no that no one
all offers considered and accepted if
you here know a lot you won't from me my
safe word is harder just got laid off
going to spend the next couple of months
working on me meeting new people having
new experiences my job was third shift
in even though I lost my job I still
sleep during the day so please message
your call between 1:00 a.m. at 6:00 I'm
six foot five inches in heels 27 but can
play 18 to 35 what else what else that
people need to know about this man what
would be I mean I guess just kind of
like maybe interests and stuff like I
like I guess arcs yeah yeah like strolls
in the park strolls in Central Park in
the spring do that okay very New York
specific stuff yeah exactly
giving money to homeless trolls in
Yosemite Park in the dead of winter
okay what about rollerblading Rolla yeah
rollerblading leather bars leather bars
that's I can um
pirate lifestyle okay yeah
steam punk rock bars yeah I like coffee
at night and whiskey in the morning yeah
that's like yeah I don't get people kind
of like he's got a good cool sense of
humor yeah stuff okay we're about out of
characters for the profile
I can't wait if you want if you end at
the end of that if you want to know more
please please hit me up the best way to
get a hold of me is calling me and
leaving me voicemails yeah
can you put all the thing that's what
you that's what I'm gonna try to do I'm
worried that we won't be able to if we
can't we it's very I'll reply to
messages with his phone number only and
then they can just call okay think about
this we really should say please be very
specific in your voicemail what you want
to do to me you never mean we have to
like I should put that right at the
beginning that kind of [ __ ] yeah cuz
otherwise where otherwise you're just
gonna get like sup man yeah so can you
call yeah I don't respond to text but I
do respond to voicemails if I don't take
your call please have you leave me a
specific message please please be
descriptive I love that winky face okay
yeah yeah yeah that's good yeah yeah
because we're funny as we want to make
this it's really about making the
messages funny the giving they're funny
voicemails yeah and we want it to be
yeah we want it to be believable so they
will do it say one thing like is this is
this guy weird there's this a gag yeah
want him to be like oh yeah I'll [ __ ]
I'll tell this guy everything he wants
to hear ultimately what we're really
looking for is like a really high or
drunk or coked up gay guy that's just
trolling and leaving 30 messages
all the time he wants those messages for
this [ __ ] guy I mean there's gonna be
so many of those it's just gonna be so
many if I gotta leave in like ten
minutes okay and your voicemails
messages please be descriptive I love
that so please tell me what you'll do to
me be descriptive I love that yeah did
wait so yeah yeah now it'll be really
funny and that will I think we're doing
that live right I think so streaming
live I think it's gonna stream live like
the one in uh that we did in Phoenix I
hope so
if not I'll just release it as you know
the regular [ __ ] we won't put it on
patreon Ryan a trip the web says
officially 100 percent over Sam being on
show Nick Youssef is 100 percent right
he can't take a joke
hashtag over it well that guy by the way
is blocked bus he's now no he is already
I know that oh yeah he didn't tag Sam so
yeah he probably can't that's that's it
yeah cuz I I put out the call one time
too I mean telling me to shut up really
actually did piss me off yeah cuz all I
was trying to do is calm the situation
down I'm like hey you don't know your
show - why would you have to shut up I
you know I seems like I we all like Sam
here but he yeah I've known Sam for 15
years yeah all of a sudden now right
yeah again I'm the one who is like vying
for not vying I'm I'm the one who's like
trying to get him to take a joke
so obviously I'm not coming here on a
serious mission to [ __ ] let him have
it I'm like hey dude we were [ __ ]
around why did you put an end to that
Brian yeah I mean like what are you
what's your
he worries me I don't really understand
right yeah like what he's like it's four
against one a mic you and Nick have been
talking to each other for five straight
minutes and most people enough more of
us haven't said a goddamn word even even
if it was four against one most people
would see that as like maybe I should
think about my position here and then
maybe uh maybe I'm wrong you haven't
said anything
I go no what look watch the episode
listen to it and then be like wow
Tebow and you can't say that I was
attacking you there's zero way you can
say that yeah zero at least we all have
a nice highlight video for the YouTube
page did you see that chick last night
yeah you did what you're telling me some
guy what guy I don't know just some
random guy was hit her up and she's like
I'm gonna go back and hook up with this
guy and she's like but he has a book he
has I feel bad because he has a
girlfriend but I don't care I'm leaving
tomorrow and I'm like you gotta be
kidding me she was cute too super cute
enough yeah do we want to put his phone
from there that's so funny some some guy
just messaged me on Instagram it's got
Lawrence and he goes I made it with a
bunch of crying laughing faces hashtag
cool down and the photo is of him also
being blocked by so then one thing I get
message is the most about on Twitter is
why am i boy dude can you please tell
Sam to unblock me I didn't do anything
wrong I'm like I'm out of all that I
have zero dogs in that fight that's so
that's all I will do is it telling
people to you know I mean he just
doesn't want anybody saying anything yes
you agree with him and his hey that's
his right innit that's unfortunate
that's his right yeah he could have been
here helping with this thing well I mean
just like for him to block people you
know if that's what he wants to [ __ ]
do
god yeah it's like fishing in a pond
just trying to get chicks at the store
it's like fishing your catch-and-release
pond yeah and then I almost had this one
in the boat and she got away by fish
Lisa do you want to go and pull his
phone number in here wait for that well
as long as we don't give it away on air
yeah well this is oh yeah yes it's not
on here so we could five five five five
five five do we want to take some calls
now baby I got um you got time to listen
to some people yeah I think I got like
ten let me actually look up the traffic
traffic right now no problem Los Angeles
noon Tuesday gridlock I remember oh wow
it's only 16 minutes to home and then I
gotta go somewhere else so that will add
another 1 minute
I gotta go next door is the punch number
so it's like 14 remainder three and I'm
not gonna remainder in there so yeah I
feel free to call anybody and whoever
the girl I guess we had a girl caller
that one in the comment feel free to
call I know a couple people tried to
call earlier and we couldn't take your
call cuz we're figuring this [ __ ] out
but feel free to call in if you want we
are here I also got friends owned by a
prostitute interesting yeah world not
really I mean oh really sucked was that
was the amount Tula so she's like I gave
her 150 bucks and then all she did but
to talk about her boyfriend her
boyfriend all the time and she's like
you're a really nice person to talk to
I'm like are you gonna suck my dick or
not cuz I gonna really see you that way
yeah
[Laughter]
3 - 3 - 8 - 7 4 - 4 that's a number
right Aaron was about to tweet it
feel free to call in and what a weird
[ __ ] errand from an objective point
of view that was weird right that was
very odd that wasn't your typical storm
out I mean I've seen him mad I've seen
storm out I didn't think he was mad
until he stood up he said he hasn't been
sleeping well so maybe that's something
to do with it maybe here we go let's
take this five seven four
what's up you're on the earth
punch-drunk where's 574 yep
what's up talk a little bit and be a
draft before we get out of here
sure no nobody wants to hear about the
end probably not but as a [ __ ] I
want to hear about it even less I want
to see what you think about a Wendell
Carter and Hutchinson team I think those
are traditional guard packs very safe
picks that aren't gonna help ya I think
the Bozak long term I think the Bulls
drafted conservatively
I think Wendell Carter's gonna be better
than Marvin Bagley actually I think he
was just used the wrong way at Duke you
think so yeah mmm Marvin bag you can't
play defense that's the that's the
problem with that guy yeah yeah yeah
yeah not he and that's huge in the NBA
if you got to score 30 a game to make
yourself worthwhile if you can't play
any defense and he can't believe any of
these I think the Bulls would secretly
be decent next year I mean they're in a
whole [ __ ] complete rebuild I don't
know about that I mean I don't think
they make the postseason but it's also
the east I'm gonna say in the east
anything could happen I just want to
rather seen them take the big chance on
Michael Porter over everybody said he's
heard a lot of people passing him
Clippers passed on him yeah mere line he
has been moving all the way to 14 at
Denver with them or after they say it's
like a bad back or something that scared
everybody off
oh his back is destroyed apparently yeah
he only played back at one point - and
look how that worked out for the Sixers
yeah but so did like Nerlens Noel right
and look at him he's yeah but no well
never had that same kind of upside maybe
people are pretty high on him for a
while right
he never had any kind of offensive game
or polish to him he was always just a
deeper what do you what you really think
the Bulls could make the playoffs next
year in the East anything is possible
and that would be the leap most
disappointing thing if they did cuz then
that's no more lottery picks and puts
them in an even bigger hole in this
rebuild yeah I know I think I think they
really gave a solid look to Porter
though right I read that he they worked
him out I'm almost more than I mean like
gave him more attention than almost
anybody about five minutes where I
thought the Clippers were gonna get him
actually you and I were texting because
Carolina was drafted right right but
Charlotte was wrapped in right after us
after the Clippers and I thought for
sure I really want to Charlotte to take
him are you Cubs or Sox have you been in
that newspaper have you been in that new
stadium in South Bend the for the minor
league Cubs actually looking at actually
running one of the apartments right
outside of there okay because they're
turning that whole neighborhood into
like a like mini Wrigley Wrigleyville
and putting like bars and shop and all
that [ __ ] we're going up right across
the street yeah I think it'd be pretty
nice how much of this make all of us cry
good by the way these are nice ass
apartments how much are those apartments
per month 700 I thought it was
exaggerating way low and dude they're
nice I got $3,000 a month apartment you
can't even rent a porta potti in Los
Angeles for 850 to live in like a home
port a home potty you can find couches
on Airbnb for 800 oh yeah like Beverly
Hills the hills it's at insane and
that's not a month is that our month oh
yeah you know it's just a couch so you
don't get a closet it's a house and your
Sitz gocubs that's dude and I know that
actual area yeah
tattoo on his right arm what it does
what is that it looks like one of those
like itches sketch things like you could
shake him and it just goes away let's
take this call you are on the earth
punch-drunk how can we help you
2 5 3 hey hey what's Brian 5 3 what's up
dude
where's 2 5 3 at Tacoma Washington okay
I just want to talk about how James
Harden won the MVP did he officially win
it
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah you want to
write him every category I'm like Sam
but uh I think LeBron deserves honey one
measure
people get tired of voting rate 7/8 of
the year though harden like he was
killing it in the first half
like it was a runaway but then I think
it would I mean I think if it was if I
if I got a vote I would have voted for
LeBron you know that they just get tired
in every category besides three-point
shooting and they tied up a percentage
and he had zero help but compared to
what harden had I mean harden had a team
around him LeBron just put in the
servers yeah exactly I don't know if
they didn't make the final should go
count against him
I didn't that's me I didn't I just heard
that right now when you and Nick just
said that I didn't know that you would
do the account do they pick based on
like regular season performance
I like playoffs included I don't
yeah it's you're not supposed to factor
it and play a whole season yeah right so
I guess that he'll just want to say [ __ ]
Oklahoma City [ __ ] Clay Bennett and [ __ ]
Howard Schultz love it that's a good
take thanks for calling bro suck it suck
it there we go
8 to 8 where are you calling from and
what can I do to help you yeah yeah baby
hey works damn yeah yes cousin Jeff this
is Ari's cousin Jeff
say boys look we got cut we got
co-workers here pulling their [ __ ] out
bald we got girls
[ __ ] winning BJ contest it's like a
complete 180 for me boys
wait what where do you why do you have
bro I'm so happy for you and are they
hiring and they're pulling out their
[ __ ] bald yeah yeah yeah you know I
just show them who's [ __ ] boss is
here too you know every once in a while
you know you got to do that [ __ ] I still
ain't got enough [ __ ] though I think
I'm pretty close boy what career field
is this yeah I'm in the cooking science
field I guess where you like you know
where you cook real good you're working
a restaurant yeah I work this restaurant
the Carolina grill and check your [ __ ]
huh so you work in a restaurant where
people are pulling out their [ __ ]
ball dicks having yeah but look what
happened was the hey cook called her
Bluff she is like she can't talk about
you know his ball he's like a sumbitch
8-ball that [ __ ] pulled that
[ __ ] right out of the fat little
a school that's the mind [ __ ] that's
classic that's how you get to see nudity
I bet you won't pull out your [ __ ]
won't suck my dick works every time I
got a little hard to ankle oh I'm not
surprised
there was a [ __ ] what about that I
was I was gonna hostess black
extravaganza show last week but goddamn
it turned into like I need reliable as
it turned into [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'd like that reminder by Jeb is in
North Carolina where that kind of thing
is accepted I just want to say I hey
what about the [ __ ] contest yep what
was that oh yeah I'm not racist my
sister gets long dick by black dudes all
the time and I'm real cool with it not
as cool as she is with it
you know what's the [ __ ] boy the
contest you said there were chicks
winning [ __ ] contest what's that
about
yeah I'm just wanting to bluntly ask her
boy she used to be a stripper too from
Virginia I mean if you can get why I'm
talking she does get me flustered up a
little bit too she's got this weird ass
last name like reveille or something
kind of kind of gets me my dirty
thoughts brewing it's dead first then
you said there was a [ __ ] contest I
can you tell us about that yes she won
the [ __ ] card but just hearsay up I
was really wanting to just straight up
ask her she's wanting to do another one
I'm gonna be the first risk okay say you
say you heard around the grill we lost
the [ __ ] contest
you heard around the relay she's a web
blast she's a waitress is that right
and once I'm here she's the waitress and
then we got this other one y'all look
I'm having a talk quiet cause she's
right around the corner I said put her
on the phone jack she's gosh Jeb put her
on Twitter on the phone okay but first
how big are your jets
mm-hmm okay hold on okay okay this is
this is gonna work
hello what's up this is still job hello
hey how's it going
you're like you're live on the on there
on the air I'll she left jab what the
[ __ ] Jeff yes yes she pulled she pulled
out like a long who's a ready for the
primetime you know hey what were you
gonna whisper about it oh yeah go back
to that well we got a very contact again
boys
he's too close to her oh yeah yeah it's
real close hey it's good talk to y'all
miss y'all will save yourself a [ __ ]
oh and you have been to jail recently no
boys I've been doing pretty good I'm
three legal actions I'm dude [ __ ] I
walked up and blazing the [ __ ] out you
know just enjoying life and [ __ ] are you
still here your grandmother's I believe
is everybody yeah I wasn't gonna make it
up the skank face but I'll pull it out
like a [ __ ] and we'll come up there but
I still might go to that Sunday show I
don't know what to do that's gangsta
mean yeah did definitely come up hey you
gotta gotta see your cousin re yeah I
really want to slap dicks with him you
know get some of that hey speaking of
Jews we got this G working here and I
consciously bash him with Jew jokes and
he keeps threatening me like he's gonna
do something I don't think he can really
do something about that [ __ ] what do you
mean like what you sue you what the
tables got turned on David you know and
graph-like
ass raped and instead of this whole
fairy tale [ __ ] about you know David
beat Goliath up it's tough that's a
great theory well Malcolm Gladwell has a
theory about that that Goliath was
actually blind so it was not even a real
pharaoh yeah Jen I guess what boys oh
yeah I knew it was coming
I knew it was coming Jeff that's a real
legitimate call that's how you do it I
really think he's gonna get calls that
photo a big day like that's a legit yeah
that's gonna get a smile where he's like
I'm assessable you got a little bit of
like a gay stance it's like
that's a hungry person hey every area
could have never heard it I know
six one three where is this hello
six one three hola ba Felicia did I miss
the girl no not yet seven six
that's a Southern California thing is
this seven six out where is this hello
Orange County herbs 909 that's also
Southern California hello 909 hello
you're on the air what's uh yeah
wondering if Sam is taking the
two-for-one bit from cheap or what is he
doing them what no he's not he turned
the doubt over he turned it down it was
really supposed to be a three for one
and he wouldn't accept that yeah he
turned it down [ __ ] dude I mean he
calls out I mean [ __ ] the Raiders in
mid-december he knows better than that
now that's gonna rip on this [ __ ]
ma'am are you gonna do he's still gonna
put a hot tub in the best friend of the
year [ __ ] thank you bro Thanks yeah I
tried to give him the offer he pays off
all the other bets that are outstanding
and I'll put dog in my house instead
that was what the offer I put it and you
want it anyway it's a win-win I've been
practicing for months bro I've been
practicing just in case I lose the hot
dog bet I got a hot tug advance right
now I mean yeah I do those squats man
the only way I can get it out is sending
a [ __ ] rescue dog Oh suck it suck it
good call
good here - five four is that right
you're on the air with punch-drunk
what is up yeah you were live sir what's
the word bird we are live
Aria is not here today's on the plane
right now heading back to Jay York was
he really was he talking [ __ ] about the
fight yeah so much yeah how are you
so re already thinks O'Neill is gonna
win easily yeah I think so do I what you
did I'm going to bog about all you
[ __ ] the Porter right the
quarter week around think has this do
you think he has it
why easily why why yeah why did buddy
say easily just you know he's got that
New York grit he's down with that
grappling Club he just got heart more
heart than that douchebag Rhino I don't
think you
yeah but heart is not a skill heart yeah
I mean we just know O'Neill is a psycho
who has spent his entire life fighting
yeah he's a trained fighter and also no
one no one ever says this to O'Neill
also has heart so if heart goes into it
he has heart and skill right that's -
yeah that's - I mean and I think if he I
love Louis - I love I like I love I want
it to be like just a long great fight I
don't want anyone get knocked out right
away I want it to be lucky for I didn't
really I think Gomez is gonna get gassed
maybe way they decided to do that is a
band that is to lure show mezes
advantage they agreed to do that wait
only if he makes weight though only if
you buy two 22 right now I look has
until August end of August no no no 13th
that's when the way Oh is that when the
fight is he could do that he could make
that way yeah he's at 222 yeah yeah he
couldn't he can make that way so yeah he
has to lose basically what 15 pounds
what's he as he said what he's doing on
the show like what's his workout it
would be hard but he could do it is he
just training in the John and he's
training with he's got a couple of guys
from one of the dudes on GAF digital
runs a grappling Club up there I hope
he's going like seven days a week
he's with Bisping - he was in California
with visiting
I think our Neil's been training with
Mickey Gaul a little bit yeah I was
wondering that too could lose been so
[ __ ] pissed about that he's gonna
[ __ ] kill Mickey if he's training
with him and so randomly Disick use like
I swear I'm not training with them but I
don't know photo of Ryan training with
Conor McGregor big J is still gonna sing
a song thank you no he's out everything
good he's team Lewis now all right
thanks for coming bro so it suck it okay
you two we already got our first message
by the way on that oh we do no way hey
this is Michael into freaky foreplay and
more if the vibes are right can't host
in my place in there and he gives us
address my private pics are unlocked for
you right here why I want to know the
reason he can't oh my god five four zero
are you there where you come from I just
want to call Ari out for not being a
real Washington Capitals fan I think
he's a little [ __ ] didn't celebrate
didn't even know which day we won the
Stanley Cup
I mean that's our yeah hey he has said
before years that he is at least a cat's
head I'll give it to him but he wasn't
excited for it oh yeah he wasn't excited
you're taking you're a big fan yeah I've
been trying to get you guys to watch it
even try to get Sam to get involved in
goddamn Vegas got a goddamn sport but
you guys don't do it sorry I know you're
not into hockey
I like the monkey brothers [ __ ] like I
like stuff like that I like hockey a bit
it's definitely not my top three but I
mean I've been to several Blackhawks
game but I went to a Kings game this
year but it's just you know and I
watched a lot of the Stanley Cup the
Vegas thing is insane they're opening
like for every game that they do in like
a like a Cirque de Soleil kind a [ __ ]
thing this is incredible it's incredible
to see yeah I was talking in a little
bit I thought it was more about
extravagant celebration just cuz I was
rooting for the other team but it's a
typical Vegas it's
it's like exactly it makes me wonder
what the Raiders are gonna be like
they're like they're gonna have that
same kind of pageantry yeah if they'll
even allow it the no-fun League will
even allow it
well yeah I was calling about that [ __ ]
too but also I want to know is GST still
addicted to kitty litter I mean from
what I understand he is he hasn't called
in in a while and I'm sure he's been
seeing aliens got you we got to get him
to come in
I mean call in Jess P hasn't called in
in a while let's see we got here
403 403 how much are you suck on eBay
what's up good what's the word bird
that's a much ma'am
crowd to see fine Annie in the building
course next course GTV
it is kind of weird to see without Sam
and Ari but that's all good
I mean Sam was here yes Ann was here ari
was never gonna be here traveling you
missed the storm off dude you miss
another storm off and now Sam is commits
a runaway on storm us for Sam why what
you guys made him up step four what
happened what do we make example I mean
we were trying to he just got his
panties in a bunch about Instagram
Instagram comments I guess oh [ __ ]
really you know I told Sammy cuz it [ __ ]
those constant let them [ __ ] be dicks
who cares [ __ ] keep doing your art [ __ ]
them I feel like this should be a rule
if Sam storms off more than five times
you should be banned from the show I
mean because it's just because it's the
same old thing that's this is just Sam's
rules let's if you do the same old thing
enough times in a row you should be you
here at Sam's show Sam's room those
rules supersede anything call her
understand when you say [ __ ] them you
mean Nick you said yeah I'm the [ __ ]
like the the star wars in cell fans okay
that's what I explained that's also Nick
Youssef cuz I was the one leaving
comments on his page that's why he got
he blocked
that's a Ryan help me to write he'll
just like basically was I
hey you're crazy right now or whatever
you're saying isn't true
and he's like block Ryan hello Ryan he
used to leave all Ryan used to leave all
kinds of comments on my Instagram about
like me being a stupid hipster and
drinking like expensive coffee and blah
blah blah and now just like yeah great
cool yeah hey Ben everything good yeah
I'm gonna have a breather next time I
come down alright so personally Sam yeah
Ryan's the best oh he is the best he's
the best caller where are you calling
from
from this is going up or she's just
gonna start getting all these today he's
not aware when it's going up this photo
from them god that first calls into
business what is it a knife what is that
at the bottom looks like all right into
knife play that wasn't our view would
have a knife play love Russian Roulette
yeah you're the last call today what's a
word hey yeah I'm calling from flight
accesed
I just I'm calling to hound you about
your site all of them Kibo when's it
coming out yeah dude
I gotta talk to my cabana right now but
it's totally done we finished editing in
about a week and a half ago and it's all
think county's gonna be putting it out
soon dude you're becoming like tool are
you I'm the opposite of Ryan Adams are
you uh coming to Scott to all things
comedy festivals not too far from you in
October t-boz album comes out four years
out of that festival
oh thanks man oh thanks man Tevan is two
different buddies
that pod parachutes and flagstaff kevo
oh I'd love to you oh yeah yeah that's
one of my one of my old jobs I was
testing parachutes for Colin oh come
come - I'll think how many Festival and
I'll suck it if you got yeah yeah you
should test parachutes luckily it now
you know only two times they didn't for
a minute there I'm like is that like in
a controlled environment where there's
like I'm like like free airplane yeah
you know but the first couple of times
you do you have to go tandem some money
that's half the fear right there's like
I don't have to be the one pulling the
thing yeah I do that yeah I would only
do it no tandem or shoot no shoot no
shoot no tandem yeah no wind resistance
I just want to plummet just like but
halfway on a flight to Hawaii or like
over the grave oh did you see that
flight with the big three players and
Michael Rapaport some guy went to open
the emergency door Michael Rapaport head
like tackle him and hold him down Joe
they were mid-flight it was Michael
Rapaport and one of those big three you
know he does the commentary for that
like Baron Davis Glen Glen Davis big
baby and if guys yeah I wonder if you
can't I don't think right no it's
pressurized there's so much pressure on
the door that apparently you can't but
they didn't know that and it was just
some random crazy guy yeah I'm not gonna
risk it yeah [ __ ] yeah what if
that guy's like an arm wrestling champ
you know next thing you know just
complete and then the only news stories
arm wrestling champ dies and crash gets
any oh yeah absolutely that sucks
well guys it's been wonderfully this was
really fun so - the [ __ ] yeah once
again I say it every other week this
could possibly be the last punch I'm
sorry Sam come back yeah come back Sam
in a better mood we'd like you every
yeah dude that was like fellas really
there's this unnecessary feel
uncomfortable I need to and we need to
tell me to shut up I look at him like
why do what now but anyways so suck it
consider it sucked and see me at the
punchline San Francisco July 5th or 7th
if you're in Brooklyn
check out the Adam for Adam page of big
joke oh yeah that's right
aka what's this [ __ ] name tinkle man
or whatever yeah look at Gabe I'm sorry
Gabe queen with games yeah I already
forgot my okay there's so many other
things after that thank you
suck it